I hate to be the one to tell you but  your father has passed  1.2 million Falls to you with a small  complication has arisen his sister was  committed to Eloise insane asylum but  she was never released we have to have  proof of her death I have to get this  death certificate from that mental  hospital Heloise that place burned down  I'm 30 years ago we're getting quick out  piece of cake  no what was that are you scared I'm  scared this is where they used to store  the dead bodies this place gives me oh  my yeah let's get the phone without your  critics have been extremely vocal about  this radical  Jesus this is not an exact science what  the hell okay now it's time for your  treatment we have to remember that we're  helping  but it's not an exact science  [Music]